we'd love you to join us to auradon prep
will you come sign king bed we are so
excited that you get to go to Oregon
dizzy we totally fell in love with you
in descendants too
you're kind you're smart you're talented
and you're Evie's favorite you deserve
so much better than life on the Isle of
the laws Evie will take great care of
you and you will be so successful in
auradon
just keep an eye on your fellow VJs
there are four new villain kids in
descendant three do you know which BK is
totally obsessed with all things shiny
keep watching for the ten things no one
realized about the new villain kids not
her mother's daughter we meet does eat
remain in descendants - she works at a
super stylish salon on the Isle of the
loss dizzy is the daughter of Jerusalem
Maine one of Cinderella's stepsisters in
Cinderella Gisela is lazy and mean but
dizzy couldn't be more different she's
super sweet and she is such a hard
worker she runs the salon and keeps it
clean she's also talented at making
accessories like the tiara she gave to
EB like father like son
two of the Nuvi kids are actually twins
squeaky and squirmy are the sons of mr.
Smee Smee was the first mate - Captain
Hook in Peter Pan Smee was a total
doormat - hook he did whatever the evil
captain wanted and he was so scared of
everything it's hard to be a pirate if
you're timid squeaky and square me are
the same way they're frightened of
everything and are really shy but they
have each other at least daddy's girls
sylia facili a is the doctor of the
voodoo master doctor facili a we saw
just how powerful dr. facili a was in
Princess and the Frog some of the bee
caves don't want to be like their
parents but Celia really wants to make
her dad proud but that doesn't make her
a villain through and through what kind
of hustle you got going on with them
I need people no hustle I got friends on
the other
now totally relates to Celia because she
used to want to make her mom proud even
though Maleficent was evil wicked
grandmother we can all agree that Lady
Tremaine was a terrible stepmother but
she was really good to her daughter's
Drizella and Anastasia however she has
not been a good grandmother she forces
dizzied to do all the cleaning at the
salon and home lady tremaine dress is
nice but dizzy is often seen wearing
rags and just look at how tense their
relationship is lady tremaine is
obviously better about losing her
servant stepdaughter so she takes it out
on dizzy but that doesn't mean that she
doesn't love dizzy in her own strange
way so excited squeaky and squirming
they look like they're scared of
everything and who can blame them
they've lived their whole life on the
Isle they're really scared of leaving
their dad behind on the Isle of the Lost
but they're still super excited they've
heard lots of stories about Oregon and
they know life is better there squeaky
and score me show us that you can be
scared and excited at the same time
what makes Celia really excited keep
watching to find out southern belle it
might seem like Celia is from the aisle
after all she lived most of her life
there but Celia considers herself
totally southern she says she's from the
south because that's where her dad's
from dr. Priscilla a really lived the
Louisiana culture and that has carried
over to its daughter your heritage
doesn't have to be where you live and
Celia really honors that Cajun lifestyle
is your heritage different from where
you live tell us in the comments below
big sister vibes did these mom grew up
with a sister who was close in age
Ursula and Anastasia mostly got along
but dizzy is an only child if it wasn't
for Evie dizzy would be super lonely she
really feels like Evie is her big sister
Evie supports her and treats our so
kindly they have each other's back and
Evie is the reason that
he gets to go to Oregon we just loved
their relationship once again
descendants shows us that you don't have
to be related to be family biggest fear
even though the twins are excited about
Oregon they're really scared leaving the
life you know behind is terrifying but
their biggest fear is leaving their dad
unlike a lot of the case sweetie and
square me have a great relationship with
their father and they are younger than
the other BK's they're afraid that
they'll never see their dad again the
Carlos reassures them that they will see
mr. Smith soon we hope they learn to be
a little less scared living the dream
life on the Isle is pretty rough and
while some of the B case may enjoy their
life or get along with their parents
dizzy isn't one of them she's dreamed
about living her best life in Oregon
forever in fact most of the BK's have
there's less crime and more happiness in
Oregon dizzy has been waiting her whole
life to get her chance and we just know
that she's awesome enough to succeed
with the chance that Edie gives her
money talks it isn't easy to be rich on
the Isle there are no castles and
everyone is kind of stuck being poor so
it makes sense that Celia is all about
money life for Celia is about business
and getting rich and she isn't afraid to
use less than legal means to achieve it
she is a skilled pickpocketer we just
hope she learns to clean up her act
which of the Nuvi case is your favorite
let us know in the comments thanks for
watching like this video and subscribe
to the things for more awesome content
see you next time
[Music]